- In the wake of a violent riot
that ended in actually
taking over the U.S. Capitol,
leaving at least five dead,
including one Capitol police Officer,
cries for removing the President
as expediently as possible are coming
from both sides of the aisle.
But this isn't an episode
of "The West Wing".
This is actually real life.
Can the 25th Amendment actually be invoked
to remove President Trump from Office?
Is that a legal possibility?
(dramatic music)
Hey, LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a constitutional scholar,
because we are through
the looking glass, people.
We are in uncharted territory,
because people are furious
with President Trump,
not just for potentially
inciting the violent mob
that eventually took over the Capitol,
but also with his lack of
a response after the fact,
his inability to calm the crowd
and basically seeming like he was AWOL.
People are suggesting that the President
is now incapable of
discharging his duties.
So, what do we do in that situation?
Well, a lot of people have
pointed to the 25th Amendment,
which was created to have a backup plan
in case the President was incapacitated
or otherwise incapable of
performing their duties.
Now, the U.S. Constitution's original plan
for what happens in the event
of a presidential disability
or inability to work
was simply for the Vice
President to take over.
But that was pretty vague.
It seems simple enough, but
Article Two, Section One,
Clause Six of the Constitution
doesn't exactly explain how to decide
when a President is considered disabled
or unable to perform the
duties of the Office.
So in 1967, Congress
passed the 25th Amendment,
which was intended to provide clarity
in these really dire situations.
And if you've ever seen "The West Wing",
you've probably seen a couple
of these 25th Amendment
scenarios play out,
but this is real life.
And the real 25th Amendment
has several sections.
The first is Section Three,
which is a part of the 25th Amendment
that has actually been
invoked several times.
Section Three of the
25th Amendment provides
that the President has the authority
to declare him or herself unable
to discharge the powers of the Office.
If the President makes this declaration,
it officially transfers
authority of the Office
to the Vice President,
who exercises it as Acting President
until the actual President
reclaims their authority
by declaring that the
disability has ended.
So, why in the world
would a President ever
willingly give a power
to the Vice President?
Well, it's generally in
times of medical emergencies
or sometimes even a
routine medical procedures.
So for example, this could apply
if the President was having surgery
and knew that he or she was
going to go under the knife
and was going to be
incapacitated for that time.
The key aspect of Section Three
is that the President has
discretion over when it applies
and when it ends.
And this has happened before,
Ronald Reagan sent a letter suggesting
that he was invoking Section Three
of the 25th Amendment when he
underwent surgery for a polyp,
George H.W. Bush was Acting President
for about eight hours while
President Reagan was in surgery.
And after that, President
Reagan took back his power
as the actual President.
Similarly, when George
W. Bush was President,
he formally invoked Section Three
of the 25th Amendment twice
when he was anesthetized
for routine medical procedures.
Each time, the Vice
President, Dick Cheney,
took over on both occasions.
And then, when the President felt better,
was declared fit for Office,
and retook their power
as the President of the United States.
And believe it or not, took the power away
from Vice President, Dick Cheney.
But while this is an
interesting history lesson,
this is obviously not the scenario
that people are talking
about in January, 2021.
What people are talking
about in the context
of basically forcibly
removed the President
from power refers to Section
Four of the 25th Amendment.
And Section Four of the 25th Amendment
is far more complicated and
contested than Section Three.
Following the siege of the Capitol,
there've been lots of calls
for invoking the 25th Amendment
and removing President Trump from power
and installing Vice President
Pence as the Acting President.
Nancy Pelosi, the Speaker of the House,
has called for Chuck Schumer,
the minority Senate leader,
though soon to be majority leader,
former Chief of Staff, John Kelly,
has called for President Trump's removal
via the 25th Amendment,
and even Mick Mulvaney,
who just resigned his post
and was the former Director of OMB,
former Director of the CFPB,
and the former White House Chief of Staff,
has suggested that the 25th
Amendment should be in play.
And all of them are referring
to Section Four of the 25th Amendment.
So, there is a process for
removing a President from power
who is either unwilling or unable
to transfer power themselves.
It's actually never happened.
The Section Four of the 25th Amendment
has never been invoked, and
obviously it's highly political.
Now, what most people think about
when they think of the 25th
Amendment is a President
who has suddenly taken ill,
maybe was in a car crash
and is put on a ventilator,
or has to go into emergency
surgery for, I don't know,
a heart condition or any
of the million things
that could actually befall
of an actual human President.
And if they are in an emergency,
if they're under surgery,
under general anesthetic,
or in a coma, then the
25th Amendment could apply,
because the President
wouldn't have the ability
to make the determination for themselves
that they have to transfer of power.
At the same time, the
authors of the Amendment
also does it cover scenarios
where the President thinks
that he or she is totally fine,
but that the Vice President
and a majority of the Cabinet think
that the President is not actually fine.
Remember that America is
a country that was created
in part because the colonists didn't want
to be ruled by King George the Third,
who was said to be suffering from madness.
So, if a President is unwilling
to declare him or herself incapacitated,
then the Cabinet and the
Vice President may act.
In these circumstances,
the Section authorizes the Vice President
and a majority of either the Cabinet
or any other body established
by law acting jointly
to declare the President to be disabled.
And for all intents and purposes,
we're talking about the Vice President
and the members of the
President's Cabinet,
of which there are 15 members.
Specifically Section Four of
the 25th Amendment provides
that quote, "Whenever the Vice President
"and a majority of either
the principle Officers
"of the executive departments
"or of such other body as Congress,
"may by law, provide, transmit
"to the President pro
tempore of the Senate
"and the Speaker of the
House of Representatives
"their written declaration
"that the President is unable
to discharge the powers
"and duties of his Office,
"the Vice President shall
immediately assume the powers
"and duties of the Office
as Acting President."
Now, the key phrase here is,
"The President is unable to
discharge the powers and duties
"of the Office."
At the moment, President
Trump is not in a coma,
he's not incapacitated,
as most people would
generally define that word.
And this might be a
little bit controversial,
but I think most people would agree,
he's not suffering from
something like dementia.
So, it could be an open question
as to whether the President's
indecision or inability
to attempt to prevent the mob
that took over the Capitol
or to effectively run the country
in the wake of this horrible tragedy,
whether that qualifies
as the sort of inability
to discharge the powers
and duties of the Office
that is contemplated
by the 25th Amendment.
Now, practically speaking,
the 25th Amendment requires a majority
of the Cabinet Officers
agree with the Vice President
the President is unable
to fulfill their duties.
There are 15 Cabinet positions,
as we've talked about.
So, the Vice President
would need a concurrence
of at least eight of
the 15 Cabinet Members
to activate a declaration
of Presidential disability.
Now, let's put aside
for the moment the fact
that the Trump Cabinet is currently full
of acting Cabinet Members
and has lost a lot of the
Senate confirmed Cabinet Members
that I think the 25th Amendment
originally contemplates,
but we'll get back to that.
But again, talking about the practicality
of this for the moment, once
a majority of the Cabinet
and the Vice President
notify the President pro tem
and the Speaker,
the Vice President immediately
assumes the power and duties
of the Office of Acting President,
but the drafters of the 25th
Amendment were well aware
that this opened up the possibility
that the President was
being removed solely
for political reasons,
like the country was just tired of him,
or the Vice President was plotting a coup.
So, the Amendment gives the
President a way to get back in
and reclaim their power
from the Vice President.
The way that works is this,
and it's a little bit complicated,
once the Vice President invokes
the Presidential disability,
the Vice President
becomes Acting President,
but the President then,
the original President,
at the time of their choice,
can transmit a written message
to the President pro tem and the Speaker,
that no disability exists
and that the President
should then resume power
of the Presidency, but the thing is,
the President doesn't get
that power back immediately.
Once the President has made a declaration
that they are objecting to the decision
of the Vice President and the Cabinet,
the Vice President and the Cabinet
then have four days to respond.
So, this sets up a potential showdown,
because the Vice President and
the majority of the Cabinet
have four days to contest this finding,
this objection by the President
if they think the President
is still incapable
of serving, of discharging the duties.
So, if in those four
days, the Vice President
and the Cabinet still
believed the President
is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of the Office,
then the decision goes to Congress.
And at that point, if two thirds
of both Houses of Congress
believe that the President
is unable to discharge
the duties of Office,
then the Vice President
continues as Acting President
until that disability is resolved
or until the end of the term.
But if the two thirds
margin is not obtained
or if Congress is in session at the time,
but doesn't vote on the
question within 21 days
of receiving the declaration,
then the President has
to resume the powers
and duties of the Office.
Similarly, if Congress is
not in session at the time
and assembles but doesn't
vote within 21 days,
then the President presumes the powers
and duties of the Office.
Like I said, this is complicated,
but really practically speaking,
the way it works is this,
the Vice President declares
the President is disabled.
So at that point, if the
majority of the Cabinet agrees,
the Vice President immediately
becomes Acting President.
At that point, the President can object.
And let's say that the
President objects immediately
at the same time that the
Vice President takes power,
then the Vice President and
the Cabinet have four days
to decide if they agree.
And if the Vice President
and Cabinet still believe
that the President is disabled,
then the decision goes over to Congress,
who have to act within
a maximum of 21 days,
although they can obviously act sooner.
Now, as I said, Section Four
has never been activated
since the Amendment was ratified in 1967,
but there were two events
during Reagan's presidency
where arguably it should
have been invoked.
On March 30th, 1981, President Reagan
was shot and seriously wounded
while leaving a speaking
engagement in Washington.
It was actually just down
the street from where I live.
President Reagan had emergency surgery
and he was under anesthesia.
His aides debated whether or
not to invoke Section Four
of the 25th Amendment.
They were all notified that
a full recovery was expected,
and decided that no
further action was needed.
But when President Reagan was shot,
Al Haig, the Secretary of
State made a huge mistake
and told the press that he was in control
while the President was in surgery.
- As of now, I am in control
here in the White House,
pending return of the Vice President.
And I'm in close touch with him.
If something came up, I would
check with him, of course.
- This was considered a
huge mistake in faux pas
and sort of demonstrated
constitutional ignorance
by a high ranking official,
because the Secretary of
State is not the person
who takes over when the
President is incapacitated.
And while many people
remember Al Haig's comments
and the constitutional crisis
that it almost created,
fewer people are aware that Section Four
of the 25th Amendment was also in play
during the waning days of
the Reagan's presidency,
because in the last
days of the presidency,
his mental status was
also questioned by staff
while he was in Office.
In 1987, former Senator Howard Baker,
President Reagan's newly
appointed Chief of Staff,
reportedly received a
memorandum from an aid
that claimed that the President
was inattentive and inept.
The memorandum went on to urge Baker
to consider the possibility
that Section Four of the 25th
Amendment might be applied.
Baker concluded that the
President was attentive and alert.
And on March 2nd, after a
meeting, he dismissed this report.
Of course, we all know how this ended,
because five years after President Reagan
left the presidency,
he was diagnosed with Alzheimer's Disease
and rarely made public
appearances after that.
But fast forward 35 years to today,
and as much as we know
about the 25th Amendment,
there's actually a lot
that we don't know as well.
We don't know if the key phrase,
"Unable to do discharge the
powers and duties of his Office"
applies in this particular
situation with President Trump.
If that was disputed,
we don't know what the
Supreme Court would say.
It's entirely possible that,
if someone does disputed this application,
the 25th Amendment, assuming
that they even had standing,
I suppose it would be a
deposed President Trump
who would be making the
claim, if they had standing,
it's entirely possible
that the Supreme Court
would call this a political question
and refuse to adjudicate it.
And the really big known
unknown is the fact
that President Trump's Cabinet
is full of acting secretaries
because he basically just
stopped sending Cabinet Members
to be confirmed by the Senate.
At the moment, we have
Acting Cabinet Members
in charge of the Department of Justice,
the Department of Defense
and of Homeland Security,
as well as the Department of
Transportation, Elaine Chao,
Mitch McConnell's wife, just resigned
from being the Head of the
Department of Transportation.
But as law professor Brian Kalt,
who is basically the foremost
expert in the 25th Amendment,
explains a lot of people assume
that Acting Secretaries can't
vote on the 25th Amendment,
but at most it's unclear.
There's potential scholarly consensus
that the Acting Secretaries
can vote based mainly
on a 1965 House Committee report.
But again, it's unclear.
And at most, if the Acting
Cabinet Members cannot vote,
then that would lower the
number of Cabinet officials
that would need to be in the majority
to invoke the 25th Amendment.
But we also don't know
if this is a complete
and total pipe dream.
People on the left have been calling
for invoking the 25th Amendment
against President Trump, basically,
as long as the President
has been in the Office.
And reports say that Vice President Pence
has no interest in invoking
the 25th Amendment,
despite the fact that there are calls
for him to invoke it
from across the aisle.
What we do know is that if the
25th Amendment was invoked,
President Trump would no longer
be President immediately.
And he wouldn't be President
for at least four days.
Then an additional potential up to 21 days
would also prevent him
from retaking the Office,
even if Congress refused to do anything.
And at the time of this recording,
there's only two weeks left
in the President's term,
and invoking the 25th
Amendment could keep him
out of all Office until
the end of his term.
And additionally, the 25th Amendment
is not mutually exclusive
to impeachment and removal,
as others have called for as well.
You can do both.
And on the other hand,
there might be a good reason
to invoke the 25th Amendment,
because it works immediately,
in part because it might be necessary
to prevent a massive wave of pardons.
Right now, Bloomberg reports
that President Trump is
considering a whole raft of people,
including himself, Mark
Meadows, Stephen Miller,
John McEntee, Dan Scavino,
Ivanka Trump, Jared Kushner,
Rudy Giuliani, Kimberly
Guilfoyle, Albert Pirro,
Lil Wayne and Kodak Black.
I'm gonna go out on a limb and opine
that that would be a bad thing.
But perhaps we're being too precious
with the Office of the Presidency.
The President is not a
king ordained by God.
Lots of democracies have
votes of no confidence
that allow the legislatures
to kick out the top executive,
effectively whenever they want.
And there's lots of good reasons
why you might want to do that.
And four years for a
President to serve their term
is a long time.
It's a long, long time.
But I leave that to you, do
you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews,
which talk about the crazy
legal issues of the day,
'cause there are a lot of them.
So, click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.